guys elon made history again earlier
this year on the 22nd of march tesla
announced its berlin gigafactory its
first on european soil and the fourth
gigafactory overall and with a fifth on
its way in texas i can't help but wonder
is there nothing this man can't achieve
but we all know that when elon wants
something he makes it happen no matter
the odds in this video i'll show you a
closer look inside tesla's first
european gigafactory the giga berlin
layout the layout of giga berlin is
simple to understand raw materials come
in from one side of the factory and
finished cars come out of the other yet
it is extremely advanced in its design
and flow roaming the floor of the
gigafactory you can really see why elon
keeps repeating that the factory is the
actual product the immense feat of
engineering is laid out in front of you
all optimized to churn out 500 000 cars
every year the production process begins
with aluminum casting that creates the
basic blocks of the cars this is where
tesla employs the giga a behemoth of a
machine that die casts aluminum to
create the main chassis elements of the
cars this is one of the most innovative
features of all tesla gigafactories as
it replaces the age-old tradition of
bolting hundreds of components together
to form the chassis instead due to the
giga presses tesla only has to deal with
three major chassis components the front
and rear structures and the car bed that
houses the battery pack this makes
production extremely efficient safe and
fast giga berlin has eight of these
massive machines we then move on to
stamping where the various shapes of the
car body for example the doors hoods and
the roll cages are stamped out of
massive sheets of aluminum these massive
stamping machines are expected to speed
up the production of the model y which
will be the main output of giga berlin
by a staggering 30 percent over previous
models on a side note this process of
die casting and stamping out parts are
integral to tesla's promise of
eventually being able to manufacture a
car for just under 25 000 wouldn't that
be something sign me up for it right
away moving on the next step in the
assembly process inside giga berlin
involves an impressive line of giant
robot hands that undertake a variety of
functions in putting the cars together
tesla first started using these
german-made kuka robot workers in 2017
in its fremont factory the robots at
giga berlin have come a long way since
then they can now take the chassis
components from the gigapresses and the
stamped out parts from the stamping
machines to create an entire model y
shell without any human intervention at
all as the unfinished shells move along
the assembly line each station has an
arm with a different function by the
time it completes this process of
assembly you will be able to recognize
the car within the front and rear crash
structures would have been bolted on the
battery pack mounted the drivetrain's
installed and the doors and roofs fitted
to form a car body and all of this is
done with absolute precision without
involving a single human hand watching
these giant arms work in perfect unison
drilling holes bolting screws and
welding pieces together has got to be
the most satisfying since inside giga
berlin the next phase is where humans
come into the picture this is where most
of the 12 000 workers inside the factory
would be employed they will work in
teams round the clock routing all the
wirings connecting the various
components together and mounting all the
various panels and parts they also
finish the interiors here and configure
the software that will be the brain
behind the car in a way after the
machines have done their jobs these
mechanics will be responsible for
building the car from the inside out
inspecting the cars thoroughly and
sending them on their way to the
logistics side of the factory where
massive containers will be waiting to
ship them all over the world of course
this is a very simplified explanation of
what's inside the gigabilin production
line there are various other technical
steps along the way that are critical to
the whole process but i hope this gave
you a sense of the scale and processes
involved inside giga berlin and the
making of a tesla car how and why giga
berlin was built
located in the southeast suburbs of
berlin on the banks of the river spree
the berlin brandenburg gigafactory more
commonly referred to as giga berlin
stretches over a massive 1.2 square
miles of cleared forest its construction
required deforesting over 900 hectares
of the grunhide forest and because of
that the project has attracted a lot of
ire from the environmental groups of the
region which is one of the reasons
behind the lack of permits elon has
always claimed that the environmental
offset of cutting down those trees pales
in comparison to the benefit the giga
berlin will deliver to the region and
the world as a whole however tesla's
lawyers had to jump through quite a few
hoops to realize his european
gigafactory dream anyways the factory is
a short 20 minute drive from the berlin
brandenburg airport along the a-10
motorway this is great for connectivity
purposes tesla chose this site for
precisely that reason the a-10 also
known as the berliner ring will be the
main road connection for the 12 000 odd
employees that giga berlin plans to hire
in the coming months although a lot of
construction is still going on as the
factory is slated to become fully
operational by the end of 2022 the scale
of it all was immense you can really get
lost in the complex if you don't have a
tour guide with you elon first announced
the idea of giga berlin in 2019 exactly
a year after a long-term lease was
signed for its shanghai gigafactory giga
shanghai started production in late 2019
and was primarily responsible for
meeting tesla's demands in the european
and southeast asian markets but when
production kicks off at giga berlin it
will be the main supplier of tesla's
model y to these markets and the
shanghai factory will focus on producing
other models giga shanghai acted as a
test bed for a lot of production
technologies and processes for tesla
which are now implemented and perfected
in giga berlin it was the first
gigafactory to take full advantage of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning in its assembly line robots
increasing their efficiency over time
this along with other production flow
optimizations allowed giga shanghai to
increase its production rate of 1 000
cars per week in early 2020 to 8 000
vehicles per week by the end of that
year these learnings were crucial for
tesla as it sought to make giga berlin
more than just a factory other than the
impressive production line giga berlin
is also designed to be the world's
largest battery production plant as well
elon announced that the factory will
have a capacity of up to 100 gigawatt
hours with plans of increasing it to 200
to 250 gigawatt hours in the coming
years to put this into perspective a
plant with an annual capacity of 100
gigawatt hours alone could produce
enough batteries for 1.3 million model y
vehicles which has a 75 kilowatt hour
battery it is staggering to think about
giga berlin's overall production
capacity when it comes to batteries and
cars and it does all this in the most
sustainable way possible when finished
the roof of the factory will be
completely covered in solar panels that
will generate enough electricity to
power the whole facility and then some
aluminum scraps from the stamping
process will be recycled as raw
materials for the gigapresses all the
water used inside the factory will be
recycled and reused even the rainwater
that falls on the property will be
harvested and stored to provide drinking
water for the employees that's not the
end of it even the complex machines
inside the factory are specially
designed to harness the heat generated
by them to provide heating during the
winter months elon has also promised
that giga berlin would give back to the
community by hiring from an exclusively
and establishing a training school for
high-tech jobs of the future so everyone
seems to be happy with the project and
the german media as well as the world is
already going gaga over giga the
imminent germany ev wars with this giant
factory elon was declaring war on the
car establishment in germany the
country's car making trio volkswagen
which includes porsche audi bmw and
mercedes-benz must really be feeling the
pressure especially after volkswagen's
dieselgate scandal of 2020 which has
frayed their relationship with the
german public and the government i think
elon and tesla have grabbed that
opportunity with both hands and stamped
their authority on the european ev
market once and for all tesla's superior
technology when it comes to the
production of its cars combined with its
cutting-edge developments in the field
of batteries and self-driving systems
gives it the upper hand in the sector
the old german car manufacturers are
still stuck at basic assembly lines
devoid of high-tech automation in fact
the launch of giga berlin has finally
brought some of them out of their
slumber following tesla's suit
volkswagen announced plans for its 2
billion trinity factory for the
production of their production trinity
electric vehicle inspired by giga berlin
volkswagen ceo ralph branstadter has
also taken up the challenge of becoming
carbon neutral with this new plant that
is slated to be completed by 2026 but to
be honest who knows how much of the
european ev market tesla would have
occupied as giga berlin would have
already churned out hundreds of
thousands of cars by then if you enjoyed
this video click the video on the screen
and i'll see you there